[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
elle fait bonsoir on sache très heureux
de vous voir vous avez l'air bien vous
allez confortable ya plus de place pour
les jambes que les autres années c'est
la version qatar airways dessert du
projet tak goo
cette année l'académie voulait créer un
nouveau césar alors on a pensé d'abord
créer un césar lgbt
et puis finalement c'est dit non on se
dit que ça allait être un petit peu trop
consensuelle donc on le fera l'année
prochaine nous fassions n'a pas grand
chose à faire il suffit juste de
rajouter une ventouse
[Rires]
c'est une indication tout cas ce
qu'écrit comprennent merci pour cette
les souvent reproché aux césars de ne
pas mettre suffisamment à l'honneur la
comédie généralement c'est le public qui
s'en charge et c'est très bien comme ça
mais on a quand même souhaitait la
mettre en avant
il ya un peu plus de 40 ans et quelques
années après avoir construit leur
théâtre de leurs propres mains la troupe
du splendid rencontrer son premier
succès au cinéma sans pouvoir imaginer
que nous serions réunit ce soir en 2021
pour la célébrer voilà vous avez un très
très gros moule un très très gros meuble
ou un très gros boulot je ne crois pas
avec des films devenus cultes comme les
bronzés les bronzés font du ski le père
noël est une ordure sur les directions
de patrice leconte et de jean marie
poiré josiane balasko marie-anne chazel
michel blanc christian clavier gérard
jugnot thierry lhermitte bruno moynot et
leurs partenaires ont fait rire la
france sur plusieurs générations en
portant un regard drolatique précis
parfois cruel mais jamais cynique sur
leurs contemporains et donc désolé mais
sur nous-mêmes avec l'air de ne pas y
toucher
l'élégance ultime de la comédie ils ont
tout simplement renouveler l'humour du
cinéma français et puis le splendide
c'est aussi un idéal celui de la troupe
dans un métier où on est très entourée
mais souvent seul la troupe leurs
caisses
c'est un peu pareil vous donne confiance
vous rend meilleur vous offre un cocon
bienveillant dans lequel vous avez la
force d'être vous-même et d'aller au
bout de votre imagination et la troupe
vous offre aussi la saveur décuplée des
plaisirs et des succès partagé et ça
c'est toujours mieux que que des succès
solitaire alors ce qui est frappant chez
chaque membre du splendid c'est cette
faculté à savoir très jeune assumer sa
nature et en faire une force
et comme tous les grands acteurs de
comédie qui n'ont pas cherché à être
autre chose
à l'image de jean yanne michel serrault
coluche et quelques autres on est venu
les chercher pour des rôles plus
dramatiques
on se souvient tous de monsieur
trop belle pour toi l'exercice de l'état
une affaire privée
monsieur batignole les témoins tandem
tenue de soirée et j'en oublie
j'en oublie beaucoup mais pardon oui je
sais ce que vous allez me dire mais rien
à part dont je retombe dans le piège
penser que la consécration ne peut venir
que des rôles dramatiques
ce serait encore dégradée la comédie non
parce que franchement gazon maudit
grosse fatigue les visiteurs viens chez
moi j'habite chez une copine les
choristes marche à l'ombre nuit
d'ivresse pas pris fait de la résistance
une époque formidable au dîner de cons
mes meilleurs copains c'était déjà pas
mal dans le genre connaissance je crois
pour toute une génération d'actrices et
d'acteurs même plusieurs vous avez
montré le groupe comme un refuge plein
d'insouciance de créativité et de joie
et j'espère vraiment qu'on ne doit pas
mettre ça uniquement sur le compte des
années 70 j'aimerais d'ailleurs
m'adresser aux apprentis actrices et
acteurs qui sont terriblement empêcher
ces temps ci vous n'avez pas de lieu
construisez le vous n'avez pas de rôle
ecrivez-le et vous trouvez qu'on voit
toujours les mêmes
faites-nous dégagé pas de problème
n'ayez pas peur
allez-y foncez au pire il pourrait
peut-être vous arriver ça j'espère ça
n'a pas duré longtemps je vais te re
terme